- Les origines russes
d'Annouchka remonte à
ses grands-parents.
Et elles ont refait surface
violemment la semaine dernière.
ANNOUCHKA GRAVEL GALOUCHKO,
artiste multidisciplinaire
- C'est physique, ça a été
comme, Poum! Comme s'il y avait
eu une bombe qui avait explosé
dans moi.
- Son grand-père a préféré fuir
la Russie au début du 20e
siècle, plutôt que d'êtr
dans l'armée rouge.
- J'ai réalisé que
j'appréhendais cette guerre
depuis tellement longtemps
parce qu'elle m'habitait.
- Et même si elle a su
se libérer grâce à l'art,
du fantôme des ancêtres,
la guerre fait remonter le poids
à la surface.
- Ce poids, il y a
une culpabilité. C'est ridicule,
puis en fait la culpabilité n'a
rien à voir avec la conscience.
- Même s'il ne porte lui norte n
plus aucune responsabilité,
Sergey se sent mal. Pas
seulement depuis la semaine
dernière, depuis la Crimée.
SERGEY SKECHKO,
montréalais d'origine russe
- C'est la honte.
C'est la honte. Au début
d'une invasion, dans ce pays,
de cette guerre qui n'est pas
juste. Voir ce soutien-là,
c'est difficile, c'est honteux.
- Et le soutien dont il parle,
c'est celui d'une majorité de
Russes envers le Kremlin.
- Comme même les membres d
famille à Moscou qui répètent la
même histoire de la propagande.
Donc, c'est tellement...
c'est tellement...
inconfortable d'en parler,
parce que je sais
qu'ils supportent l'annexion de
la Crimée, je sais
qu'ils supportent la guerre.
- Ce scientifique a quitté
la Russie après ses études,
et il se pose aujourd'hui
la question.
- Probablement si je restais,
je serais comme eux.
- Ah, oui?
- Je ne sais pas. Parce que
la propagande est tellement
puissante.
- Il dit aussi comprendre
ceux qui ne manifestent pas en
par crainte de
représailles.
Mais regrette que nombre de
ses anciens concitoyens ne
s'informent pas mieux.
- Les gens ne veulent pas ça,
ils ne veulent pas savoir. C'est
juste peut-être plus facile pour
eux de brancher lae
et écouter ce qu'ils disent.
(violente explosion)
- Et toute cette actualité donne
une résonnance troublante à
un poème qu'Annouchka avait
écrit pour son grand père.
- "La guerre immole
La jeunesse folle.
La steppe brûlait,
Sa folie t'emportait
Sur le noir cheval
Se ton rival
Pour te clouer
À l'arbre des morts
Où pleurent encore
De vieux remords.
- Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio Canada, Mon